bonjour thomas nolan de la fichiers de
la neuville merci de répondre à nos
questions vous êtes également auteur du
livre la grande glaciation économique
aux éditions en bios à paraître
prochainement déclaration commune
symbolique ou véritable moyen de
pression diplomatique vous dire que
l'épidémie de kampala virus n'est pas
permis de véritablement modifier les
équilibres géopolitiques
aujourd'hui on voit un certain nombre de
pays qui sont sur le même axe
géopolitique et qui s'oppose
effectivement à une guerre économique
menée par les états unis
une guerre qui se fait de façon
totalement transparente et pratiquement
inaudible puisque ces sanctions
financières gêne le commerce entre les
états mais n'apparaissent pas au grand
jour mais selon vous c'est un moyen de
pression ou c'est une déclaration
symbolique pour répondre à ma question
c'est un moyen de pression sur
l'amérique mais sachant qu' il existe
une véritable lutte aujourd'hui contre
ces puissances telles que continental
quel tel que l'iran la russie la chine
et la puissance économique américaine
qui dont l'économie a été véritablement
congelé par an par la crise sanitaire
donc ces puissances ne bénéficient
aujourd'hui de cette glaciation pour
donner un coup d épaule et tenter
d'affaiblir ses sanctions unilatérales
et mais quelles conséquences
est-ce que cet appel commun peut
redistribuer les cartes sur l'échiquier
mondial géopolitique diplomatiques avec
deux axes opposez vous avez évoqué
justement le mot axes d'un côté des
occidentaux et de l'autre côté les
signataires de ce texte
vraisemblablement la déclaration commune
n'aura pas de conséquences géopolitiques
il s'agit surtout de fédérer des pays
qui sont déjà liés les uns aux autres
notamment en amérique du sud puisque les
pays qui sont signataires de la
convention appartiennent déjà à une
organisation aux petites communes
mais cela n'aura pas pour effet de
remettre totalement les cartes
michelle bachelet la haut commissaire de
l'onu aux droits de l'homme s'est dit
favorable à un assouplissement des
sanctions économiques à l'encontre de
ces pays
quelle est la véritable marge de
manoeuvre des nations unies les états
unis au cours des dernières années ont
superbement ignoré les dés sont signés
et mener des interventions militaires au
mépris du droit international et
sortants en compte les avis du conseil
de sécurité des nations-unies reste un
forum où les pays peuvent encore
s'exprimer librement
mais ce sera sans sans réel effet sur
les rapports de force dans l'immédiat
mais le temps là que l'histoire
s'accélère aujourd'hui et la chine
connaît une certaine montée en puissance
il n'est pas dit que il soit aussi
facile aussi simple pour les occidentaux
de mettre un de manière bien des
sanctions dont les années à venir
quelle est la valeur contraignante
juridiquement parlant de cette
déclaration commune il faudrait
véritablement que les etats-unis se
mettent à respecter les décisions du
conseil de sécurité pour que les acteurs
géopolitiques qu'ils sont le pendant des
états unis puissent avoir avec la bobine
est une action qui devraient être les
effets juridiques
aujourd'hui c'est en fait c'est la loi
du plus fort qui qui fait kiffer le haut
merci thomas a fléchi de la neuveville
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
géopolitique titulaire de la chaire de
géopolitique à la school of business de
rennes et plus est également auteur du
livre à paraître la grande glaciation
économique aux éditions bios